on ne s'imagine pas que derrière ce mur
tagué
se cache une cuisine aux airs de
laboratoire ici oubliez les serveurs et
les à table et entre amis les seuls
interactions avec les clients se font
par cette fenêtre mais andré a créé du
lien d'une autre façon l'expérience
client allait
elle est différente on n'a pas ce
contact avec le client c'est une autre
pression c'est une autre pression mais
disons qu'on essaye de les retrouver
aussi sur les réseaux d'avoir cette
communauté de l'est de les retrouver de
faire participer sur les réseaux est de
pouvoir créer du contact comme ça
finalement aujourd'hui il enseigne
reçoit près de 90 commandes par jour
merci et bonne journée et bon courage et
propose trois cuisines différentes
le concept séduit va même jusqu'à
inspirer nous donne même envie de
nourrir c'est ce que j'ai des projets
pour ma vie du coup ça me donne envie
j'aime bien la cuisine donc ça te donner
des idées j'ai besoin de commander
quelque chose et puis repartir avec j'ai
pas besoin de quelque chose en plus pour
information de la publicité tout ce que
j'ai besoin c'est de pouvoir manger à la
musique les cuisines fantômes se sont
surtout développé durant les différents
confinement pour autant elle n'inquiète
pas les restaurateurs traditionnels
il ya encore des chefs cuisiniers qui
aime faire plaisir à leurs clients au
salé venir voir en salle comme un client
qu'on plaisir il ya il ya des serveurs
qui sont passionnés de leur métier donc
non je suis pas inquiet du tout à peine
installé andreas imagine déjà cuisiné
pour des festivals ou encore ouvrir un
second établissement